Transcriptor: Laura Mancuso
Revisor: Larisa Esteche
¿Quién le puso género a las profesiones?
¿Ustedes saben?
Porque yo no.
Más allá de que me dediqué a estudiar,
a leer, a asesorarme, a charlar,
no encontré un solo nombre responsable
de esta definición histórica.
Docencia.
Carrera social.
Femenina.
Mecánica, construcción,
tecnología, ingeniería. Masculina.
Más allá de la obvia brecha que nos separa
del hombre, esta temática parece
haberse definido por decantación.
Desde chicos nos crían diferenciando el
género, mostrándonos que todo ya está
hecho para los nenes y las nenas:
lo celeste para ellos,
lo rosa para nosotras,
un videojuego para ellos,
una barbi para nosotras.
Y yo me crié con cuatro hermanos varones.
La única mujer y la más chica.
Se imaginarán lo masculina
que era mi casa.
Y durante las tardes mis hermanos se
juntaban a jugar a los videojuegos, tiros,
guerra, auto, fútbol. Eran para ellos,
diría mi abuela.
Porque todos tuvimos una abuela o alguien
de nuestro entorno muy tradicional,
que desde chicos nos iba contando qué era
para ellos y qué para nosotras.
Y yo amaba los videojuegos de carreras,
de autos y de vez en cuando, cuando mis
hermanos estaban de buenas,
me los prestaban.
Y un día me encontró mi abuela, se me
acercó y me dijo: “Nena, le vamos a decir
a mamá y a papá que te compren
un videojuego de princesas.
Estos no son para vos.
Vamos a jugar que la abuela te preparó
la masa con harina y agua”.
O sea que ellos sí podían poner toda su
imaginación, creatividad, jugar a los
videojuegos y yo tenía que poner toda
mi creatividad en la harina y el agua.
Un poco injusto, ¿no creen?
Les propongo que los juegos
no tengan género.
Los prejuicios, los preconceptos o las
convenciones que surgen en la familia
desde que somos chiquitos
nos llevan a pensar de una manera
que puede influenciar y hasta perjudicar
nuestra vocación.
Y ahí la gran pregunta:
¿Qué quieres ser de mayor?
Inocente.
Recuerdo esa pregunta resonando sobre
mi cabeza durante mucho tiempo.
Pero es una pregunta muy simple.
Seis palabras reparadoras
sin objetivo de daño.
Pero no me digan que no fue la primera
vez que se sintieron en jaque.
Porque yo sí. Claro, tras años de haber
recibido juguetes orientados a la
docencia, al maquillaje, al baile, a la
cocina, imaginarme siendo desarrolladora
de videojuegos no me iba a salir
muy espontáneamente.
Y ahí nuevamente aparece alguien
de nuestro entorno que nos empieza
a explicar que hay carreras que no son
para nosotras. Un discurso silencioso
y muy arraigado que nos dice “eso
es más de hombres”.
Pero yo les quiero contar
sobre algunas mujeres.
Quiero saber si las conocen.
Si yo les digo “Emily Rowling”,
¿saben quién es?
Margaret Hamilton.
Ada Loveless, Elizabeth Chosen.
Dos décadas antes de que se recibiera la
primer mujer ingeniera en Estados Unidos,
Emily Rowling supervisó una de las obras
más extraordinarias de Nueva York:
el puente de Brooklyn.
Margaret Hamilton diseñó el software
que llevó al hombre a la luna.
Ada Lovelace fue la primera
persona que programó.
Elizabeth Geffen fue la primer mujer
recibida de ingeniera en Argentina
en 1918.
¿Cuántas Emilis, Margaritas, Elisas,
Adas, hay ahí atrás?
¿Cuántas Marías, Teresas, Susanas, se
quedaron queriendo estudiar estas
carreras, pero no se animaron
a romper con estos estereotipos?
Este discurso silencioso las terminó
convocando hacia otro camino.
¿Pero ustedes se imaginan qué sería de la
tecnología con la creatividad femenina,
de las matemáticas
con el ingenio femenino?
Sí, lo imaginamos y lo sabemos porque
muchos de los descubrimientos que se
hicieron en la historia fueron hechos
por mujeres, mujeres que se animaron
a romper con estos paradigmas.
Mujeres que no solo fueron
grandes por sus acciones,
fueron grandes porque se animaron
a decir “yo quiero, yo puedo”.
Y si por casualidad nos imaginábamos como
grandes ingenieras, desarrollando
soluciones, seguramente y sin malas
intenciones, nos lleven a pensar que esas
carreras no son para nosotros.
O lo que es aún más triste,
que no seríamos competentes frente
al hombre en ese rubro.
Ante estas negativas se imaginarán que no
hay muchas chicas que elijan este camino.
Entonces, creo que como sociedades
avanzadas y en pleno auge, deberíamos
reflexionar que para que los niños y
niñas tengan plena libertad de sus
futuros, las carreras no deberían estar
teñidas de construcciones sociales
alrededor del género.
Y así sí, el abanico de oportunidades
sería muchísimo más amplio, tanto para
ellos como para nosotras.
Pero esto no es tan fácil, porque aún hoy
seguimos enfrentando barreras que nos
impiden acceder a las carreras
masculinizadas, a que nos animemos
a estudiar estas carreras.
Es muy importante
que desde chicos nos cuenten
una historia diferente.
Que no nos marquen nuestra capacidad
diferenciándola con la de un hombre.
Que no restrinjan nuestros sueños,
simplemente nos dejen imaginar, soñar
sin ponerle género a una profesión,
a un sueño.
Esto es tan importante que tiene
que empezar en las escuelas.
Las escuelas tienen que enseñarnos
a romper
con los paradigmas.
También nos tienen que contar
que las carreras no tienen género
y que las mujeres podemos hacer todo
con toda libertad, al igual
que los hombres.
Pero aún es difícil.
No es solo competencia
de un padre con una hija.
Esto es competencia de todos, porque todos
traemos estos sesgos que nos quitan
libertad de diálogo, libertad de
pensamiento, libertad de acción.
Todos, hombres y mujeres.
Tenemos filtros o marcos
que nos predeterminan.
Eso no es libertad.
Ni ajena ni propia.
Entonces, si un papá o alguien de nuestro
entorno no quiere acompañar en
nuestra elección de vocación, que nos dé
plena libertad, que lo haga sin sesgos,
sin condicionamientos.
Pero yo los invito a que todos revisemos
estas viejas costumbres.
Si a mí me gustaban los videojuegos,
debería haber sido fiel a mí misma.
Y la tecnología es una brecha
de género. Sí, una más.
Pero ¿qué es la tecnología?
¿Para qué sirve?
La tecnología sirve para resolver
problemas de manera rápida,
eficiente, efectiva.
Es un conjunto de herramientas, de
procesos, de acciones que nos hace
la vida más fácil.
Pero analicemos
si le hace la vida más fácil a todos
o no, porque si no es universal,
no es equitativa.
Hace más de doscientos años que el mundo
no atravesaba cambios sociales,
económicos, sanitarios y tecnológicos
tan bruscos y profundos.
Sin duda la pandemia aceleró en un año lo
que podríamos haber demorado una década.
Nuevas tecnologías se hicieron presentes,
otras se democratizaron, pero las viejas
desigualdades continuaron tan renovadas
como las nuevas tecnologías.
Y los estereotipos de género pusieron a
los hombres como los protagonistas
de las carreras tecnológicas.
De hecho, es uno de los sectores
con menor participación femenina.
Acá me quiero detener y compartirles
unos datos.
Entonces, ¿sabían que solo el 33 %
de las inscriptos a las carreras STEM,
que es la ciencia, la matemática, la
ingeniería y la tecnología, son mujeres?
Si nos enfocamos solo en tecnología, 16 de
cada 100 mujeres eligen este camino.
Y hacía cincuenta años que las mujeres
elegían más estas carreras, era mucho
mayor el porcentaje de mujeres
que elegían este camino.
Pero enfoquémonos en Argentina,
relacionemos género con ingeniería
y los números son un poco peligrosos.
En los últimos años se graduó
un ingeniero cada 3000 hombres.
Una ingeniera cada 10 000 mujeres,
Uno cada 3000.
Una de cada 10 000.
Y esto sucede porque los estereotipos
de género afectan la confianza
de las mujeres.
Nosotras aún hoy seguimos enfrentando
barreras que nos impiden acceder
al mercado laboral.
Y las que ingresan se encuentran
en condiciones salariales y promoción
profesional menores a las de ellos.
Lo cual profundiza
las desigualdades socioeconómicas.
No nos sentimos tan atraídas
por estas carreras como
los hombres.
Y la consecuencia de esto es que los
puestos, como las carreras tecnológicas,
terminan siendo masculinizadas.
¿Ustedes sabían que sólo el 6 % de
las aplicaciones móviles desarrolladas
a nivel mundial fueron hechas por mujeres?
Necesitamos más mujeres, más mujeres
que se animen a crear tecnología,
más mujeres que sean parte de esa mesa
de toma de decisión tecnológica.
No debería importar el género
al elegir una profesión
y trabajar en ella.
Y todos somos responsables.
Hombres, mujeres, jóvenes y adultos.
La tecnología no para de avanzar.
Y si nosotros seguimos sin despertar
vocación en niñas,
nosotras, las mujeres, no vamos a tener
plena libertad de elegir
los trabajos del futuro.
Yo hace 7 años que trabajo en tecnología
y por supuesto no elegí una carrera
tecnológica de base.
Elegí una social.
Pero el día que entré lo vi todo.
Tecnologìa igual hombre.
Era muy difícil cruzarse con mujeres.
Pasillos repletos de hombres,
reuniones masculinizadas.
Y lo peor de todo:
toma de decisión por un solo género.
Hoy es muy difícil contratar mujeres que
se hayan animado a subirse a este barco
y sean parte del mundo de la innovación.
Pero necesitamos más mujeres.
Necesitamos más oportunidades
para mujeres en tecnología.
No le pongamos género a los juegos,
no le pongamos género a las profesiones.
Las sociedades deben funcionar con ambos
géneros y así vamos a lograr
un mejor mañana.
Porque la inclusión siempre, pero siempre
nos va a beneficiar a todos.
Muchas gracias.